[Music]
so
[Music]
it's kirby's latest unforgettable 3d
platforming adventure kirby and the
forgotten land
it all takes place in a mysterious world
with an unusual mix of nature and
civilization to rescue the kidnapped
waddle dees kirby sets off on a new
adventure
[Applause]
introducing
mouthful mode
inhale a car to zoom around
[Music]
a vending machine to attack with juice
cans
become a piercing co
with mouthful mode new actions will be
available for kirby depending on the
object he inhales
[Applause]
enjoy exploring with new moves different
from copy abilities
kirby can even weaponize a mouthful of
water like this
as kirby rescues waddle dees waddle
d-town will continue to grow and more
resources will become available
at waddle dee's weapon shop familiar
copy abilities can be evolved
[Music]
evolve copy abilities to expand kirby's
range of attacks
they'll also change kirby's appearance
and make him even more powerful
[Music]
some copy abilities may have stronger
involved forms
[Music]
a new adventure awaits our pink puffball
[Music]
who are the beasts back
what are these enemies trying to do
can kirby restore peace to this world
kirby and the forgotten land launches on
the nintendo switch system march 25th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop